I you are sealed stuck in your house you
cannot get out the nor can you escape
your nightmare prepare to get scared
that's my prepared to get scared face
right there right there yi yi can you
everyone at it what is that oh fast
loads I like that what is that noise
it sounds like bugs or something else I
better get my laptop and get that what
the babe I'm an orderly Barbie alright
alright regular Tuesday huh my doors
locked goddamnit I better find that
lantern it's probably in here oh no wait
I remember now
I put it in the top drawer actually no I
forgot oh wait I remember now
I put it I put it behind this I mean I
put it in the PAI but I got dammit I
don't remember I'm a [ __ ] wrong
person alright
if Israel in my house looks awful
where's my land and just give it to me
that is this I pull back yet nothing my
house funny huh let's go let's go let's
go
Oh No that's the biggest better I ever
seen and a statue I don't like this very
much hey ah ah I should live no quick
why not in my wife let my torturous and
my did referring to his penis I knew it
was something with you that's why you
can never trust them never all right
they said later I'm sorry get it like
this
go I'm so sorry literally tortious all
right [ __ ] all right [ __ ] all
right but yeah
all right I'm letting that and I'm
tapping that all right cool cool yeah
let's go
hey better are you happy now do you feel
better about yourself you feel better I
should just try to sleep till morning
good idea sleep it out girl alright I'm
good you are tonight to my mother
it means you're sleeping but beware you
can still down no nightmare amount that
thought is luck that it was really
hoping for not having to go in this
corridor fauna
in here
I don't like this very much okay let's
go it's cold
that's calm regular Sunday happens all
the time when I dream I keep turning
around because I expect something back
that then in this [ __ ] goer I can't I
can't look looking again for now at
least
okay well yeah just gotta go over it
we're just gonna go over here I know it
was bad ID I know it was a bad you have
learned that oh no I didn't even have
laughs now why am I so slow
jaysus crazy life depends on it alright
alright we're good we're good
we're so good I never been better in my
entire life alright I'm just gonna go
here cannonball business Hey
I'll snap i snap on something damn it
this is 24 tonight that I didn't get any
sleep at all at this continuous Isleton
insane as well any for sure god damn it
I don't want to turn insane
I did I do to deserve this at least
someone close to Claude no still nothing
in the closet can I refill my oil hey
works wait all right nice thought I am
trusted yeah Jesus guys you never listen
to you and don't talk to the barrel I
don't know I don't know that doesn't
work now why do I gotta do
maybe there's something new no there's
not all right fine fine fine
I don't know why that sound out now
there's Locke everywhere cool
no it's fine yes I have an Eastern
storage key I guess this is here of
course is not here so amazing lonely I'm
sorry I'm late sorry sorry defense you
that's that's more like travel for me
alright let's go check all the door Oh
what the wait a minute wait a minute
Alice Bailey
but the [ __ ] are you doing Jesus Christ
you thought you were gonna play
disgusting study without me
no you're not no you're [ __ ] now
seriously seriously Alice talk all right
all right
and maybe I should take a break from
guts the stories related to me and that
this what are you talking about I'm not
a little Oh see that's what happens when
you offend me
I am so fond of dear success all right
Billy this is no time for break dancing
but I wanted so much fun that wow look
at the arm yay yay I call this a booty
slap Jesus Christ pity stop [ __ ]
around with everything Caramba
alright let's go in here follow Jesus
Christ get those long and they awfully
no open is supposed to going down I
don't know I'm sorry but you are golden
edition Stefano you know everything
cause I an know everything I'm like a
god I used to be a guard once and I was
like me really Savannah yeah it's a
twist I [ __ ] the coffee mill of today
I learned that no no no no no no no
sing with me mister check glad Nana Nana
Nana Nana wladim them by night at lad
hey what he did that's what I'm saying
good no sorry mr. Chang not a good
singer subway sing okay okay
I'm Aladdin Jesus Christ be that you
always wasted all right no no pin it
when I say my breakdancing but it's so
much fun all right
oh no nothing nightmare mode not again I
don't like night Madame Oh
you are in nightmare mode and you are
breakdancing stuff
yeah fine it's the founder where do you
go where do you go
it's fine out you in here Bauhaus Raja
Reverend lucky barrels all right we need
to find stuff hey Clara Edna and red new
March 6
yuck hadn't eaten I've hidden the key
and the [ __ ] I mean this more room under
one of the bass I know where's the key
now you're like how there yes right Oh
No
oh no I knew it you don't know he knows
I'm here now what's I didn't cause it
all right it's cool it's cool oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
which one which one
pick with it out and class all right
weekend get his ass look at his ass
Carol damn that ass is fine it's a fine
ass all right
he's gone gone [ __ ] I think at least
nope nope he's not God
chill out in the closet chill out in the
closet
oh how the [ __ ] that happened
let's go um
now I likes you know one
have a nice butt you could do modeling
though oh oh
is he gone
no he's not gone
goddamnit I think I have to run for it
alright in three
one
doofy ah okay
all right it's good yes all right I got
oh no I don't know I'll snap oh snap
bow shot oh snap all right all right
it's cool it's cool it's cool it's cool
it's cool well wait Oh what did I do
wait am I supposed to go it's not bad
all right let's go here let's be quiet
it's locked - oh yes I have to get
forgot about [ __ ] oh no oh no this is
trouble all right let's just be really
careful I see
okay he's [ __ ] up it's cold it's cold
it's cold it's cold it's cold it's cold
it's cold it's cold it's cold let's go
let's go it's not go a psycho a psycho
psycho psycho
oh oh oh shout it out break ass back -
all right all right
man but this is with all his nightmares
what what did I do to design this all I
wanted was to become a professional
breakdancer and look at me now mom look
at me now look at me now so take a look
at me now while I pick up the oil and
pick up the keys like a boss and loot
these drawers lying about and raided and
ah anyone entering this house must not
refrain from a great evil lies in wait
to devour anyone into its dark cruel
grip of a thousand nightmares oh no a
thousand I only been like 28 oh no how
am I gonna smile I like this house now
it's sure still there Oh No
yes okay I think somebody logged words
how the [ __ ] am I supposed to know it's
not that long this one stop wait ok ok I
Maui's in my line let's go let's go
inside that wall
[ __ ]
right so that one either okay oh there
we go
all right sweet sweet all right let's go
up here [ __ ] I mean bro I was talking
about barrels
there you go Wow double barrel you can't
make love when I'm in front of me
reproducing barrels I don't know all
right let's check this out hey don't
come at me
[ __ ] you bow everyone else apparently
gets super scared when I say shot bow
I'm sorry but my hey third four barrels
will never never never never never never
never never knew no no never knew no no
heaven is never knew period really baby
yeah yeah
[Music]
Hey Ya a car we feel how to learn action
all cool and I should snowball outside a
pool this one's like hello Juliet I
would Rob Matthew all night long and
these are like yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and this one is like has a passion oh I
just recognize it's so fat and this one
has a tennis ball as a tennis ball and
this one is like this one is like I'm
gonna hear bras like a baby you enjoy
subscribe we will read the day I'll see
you tomorrow
[Music]
oh my goodness Oh get out of my face